hi my name is kirsch aderaz
i am the cto and a co-founder for
corellia biosystems
um and today i'm going to talk about
next generation protein assays
and how this assays enable precision
medicine and data
driven biology to serve the
broad audience i categorized my
presentation into different sections
that would be easy to navigate
so we'll start with proteomics in the
age of omics
let's start with like what proteins are
proteins are large complex molecules
that play many critical roles in
biological organisms
uh they serve essential functions in all
biological entities from
50 nanometer size viruses to 100 feet
long
mammals like a blue veil um they are
made of
long chains of different combinations of
20 different amino acids in
especially in case of humans and and
after
this like long chain falls into itself
that specific shape and mechanical
properties matters so we will discuss
more about that
so proteins take care of the essential
functions in a biological entity so
biologically is a complex organism it
involves a lot of
functions from cellular to organism
level and all of these functions are
taken care of by
different types of proteins so let's
look at the defense function so
antibodies immunoglobulins
bind specific foreign objects to help
protect the body
enzymes all of the enzymes are proteins
carry out almost all of the thousands of
chemical reactions
that take place in cells including
reading genetic information stored in
dna or synthesize different molecules to
certain different functions
a lot of proteins act as messengers they
translate singles
to coordinate biological processes this
can be from cell to cell or
cell to tissue or organ to organ uh
one example is for example growth
hormone or like most of the hormones are
in this category and also cytokines are
also in this category
they also provide structural support for
cells and on
larger scale as well they allow the bad
body to move so if you
if you kind of intend to move your arm
what happens actually resilience of
actual proteins are moving on top of
each other
collectively contributing that
macroscopic
movements of of your of your body part
they also take place in uh take role in
transport and storage
uh binding atoms on small molecules
within cells throughout the body for
example ferritin in this case
helps with the with the iron metabolism
it's
it kind of captures and releases iron
depending on the case
similar similarly hemoglobin for example
cures oxygen from lungs to
to the tissue so protein data is
critical and complements the genetic
genetic sequencing data over the last 20
years thanks to the revolution
in sequence and technologies like
sequencing time and cost dropped
significantly that created a huge
amount of like information wealth in the
genomic space
and if you kind of like compare the
complexity like definitely that
value of information is like super
valuable uh
no one can ignore that uh but when you
look at like protect domain
there are about like 20 000 genes in the
human body and they provide
a roadmap to help in the protein inside
protein side
it is way more complex there are about
like one more than one million
functional diverse proteins doing
different functions they these proteins
interact with each other they change
each other and
and and they are the kind of what give
you the picture
of what's happening what is really
happening in the biological
entity at that given time so if if the
genes are giving the roadmap
we would say that like proteomic
snapshot
would give you the real-time traffic of
what's happening
so let's look at a specific case of like
cell division cycle so this is a
cycle that's highly regulated process it
involves a lot of feedback mechanisms
and auto proteins and signaling
molecules play in this in this feedback
loop
and it's really it's it's part of it
it's very complex and
most of the actual functions in in cell
and also like tissue level organ level
goes through like similar pathways that
actually
uh tens or hundreds of like molecules
proteins interact with each other to
collectively
uh get cell to do some some some tasks
so let's look at the
case of rust protein here for example
this last protein
gets on and off uh by the inputs coming
from
other surrounding proteins and or like
molecules
and and that actually triggers signal to
the cell
nuclei that actually hey it's time for
like
cell division so get prepared so if that
rust molecule for example
protein gets modified by because of a
mutation
or another like toxic substance gets and
turns the rust on permanent what happens
actually cells get
to the crazy cycle of division so it
doesn't listen to like feedback
mechanisms and start to like divide
crazy so
unless like other other
cells surrounding like like that
biological entities defense mechanism
notices that
this then turns into a tumor basically
so there are so many proteins
involving in this in this like
simplified
uh process and they take care of like so
many different essential functions but
also this means that so many ways things
may go wrong
so from the disease perspective most
diseases
are actually viewed and targeted from a
proteomics perspective
as a result of a functional change of
the protein so proteins are working like
k
key luck combination like so for example
assuming that
your key loses one of the to it and and
it no longer like opens the lock so
similarly a functional change of the
protein it results in a
chain shape a change in the shape that
results that protein may not be able to
perform its function uh so basically
that's
that's a disease uh or or a disorder or
upward down regulation of a protein so
proteins at the end even like they do
individually
there's the impact is in a collective
behavior so in that sense
uh their cause concentration needs to be
in the kind of like certain range if it
is below or
above that certain rate then that's kind
of like as disease or disorder state as
well
uh similarly like in case of an
infection what but you have an
infection is another object under the
body and
and triggers other functional things
in his interest
which involves intruder proteins and
through the functions basics so in that
sense you can
view infection as a way of like you know
from a proteomic domain as well
so if you look in that way the therapy
is also come in that perspective so most
therapeutic applications aim either to
like in that perspective inhibit or
peripheral proliferate a protein
function like ie control it
or reinstate the lacking or essential
protein function uh
and if either of these not possible like
literally the therapy is to supply the
end product
uh that couldn't be produced by a
problematic protein from the
function like in case of for example
insulin in diabetes here
you have to monitor it outside the body
like by measuring the glucose level
and then and then administer actually
hormones uh through a therapy such that
actually you can
regulate the blood sugar levels so if
you look at the top selling 20 drugs
these are 2018 numbers
so i kind of categorized the mechanism
of action in the table
so what you see here all of these
proteins
sorry all of these drugs excuse me all
of these drugs they are targeting a
protein
so first of all they're all of them
they're targeting protein
in addition to that like 11 of them uh
are
also proteins themselves they're like
antibodies or or
or proteins or fusion proteins they are
aiming to fix bind do something
to some other protein in the in the
biological entity
historically speaking antibiotics
painkillers
they were like blockbuster drugs of the
previous decades and and they're the
same they also they were they were also
mostly targeting proteins directly so
how does the future look
so we are hearing actually a lot of like
promising technologies that will
especially uh target genetic disorders
or or mutations and and like through
gene therapy
through vital vectors or gene editing
targeted gene editing through cruise
part or other technologies coming up i'm
sure like more interesting stuff will be
coming we will be hearing
so although these approaches will target
the dna directly the efficacy and
checkpoint assessments are still
proteomics so don't forget that
this therapy is still aimed to modify a
proteomic function or fix it
via modifying dna so so in that sense uh
importance of proteins or like targeting
protein perspective
is is not changing at all so two major
conclusions of the section so the need
for actionable data that reflects the
actual state of the biologic entity
is increasing it's not decreasing the
proteins in that
scheme will be increasing the part of
the story in understanding disease
state and therapy development efforts so
we are changing years to section two so
protein testing and human essays
so waste of test proteins in this case
like what what i mean by the test is
like presence
and concentration so chromatography mass
spectroscopy
vascular blotting and cell-based assays
are highly utilized in discovery and
earlier such phases
so they shed a lot of light in early
stages
but in later stages once you identify
your target once you know like what
proteins you're dealing with
uh immune essays are a lot more
straightforward
they are like well characterized
beforehand so you just like buy a kit or
like
brew your in-house elisa and then you do
that repeatedly for your experiment so
in that regard
in all of the later stages immunoassays
are the workhorse
for like testing proteins and although
we are discussing mostly around like
pharma it's
uh it's also look just outside we know
that what's
uh out there outside the pharma uh
even essays are the workers technology
for measuring biomarkers
ubiquitously so in that sense uh their
applications cover not only farm r d but
also like health monitoring
infectious disease monitoring
environmental monitoring
agriculture and food safety and also
animal health so all of these areas
are served by the general immunosame
market which is totaling about
a 17 billion dollar market which is
growing every year
three to five percent so getting back to
the pharma uh so even assays
use cases in pharma in many cases
monitoring protein levels and function
help it's first of all diagnosing the
problem right so before you kind of like
develop a solution
you need to understand what is the
problem uh you need to understand the
problem well enough slash to make sure
that you can then
start thinking developing and then
implementing therapies so in that sense
definitely diagnosis is one way in that
case actually protein
and immunoassays are highly utilized
uh developing therapies like when you
are developing the therapy putting the
work in the in the lab
uh most of the actual essays involve
immune says
checking terror for safety toxicity and
side effects like what kind of like
other like alarming molecule cytokines
are released when you administer that
drug to
your cells to small animal or later
stages in humans for example
what kind of toxins you observe all
these essays are also
following different protein levels that
indicate actually a different
toxic behavior or response from the
biological entity
similarly monitoring to therapy efficacy
like some some therapies need to be
kind of like tuned for the individual
patients
in that sense you need to kind of
measure something and then administer
the drug
accordingly and sometimes stop the
therapy so in that sense
you have like feedback loop where the
proteomic domain
is providing you the data actionable
data
similarly monetary immunity past
infection humidity through vaccination
all those areas are served by
immunoassay so
that's kind of like this this is fresh i
want to kind of like
call the audience to think about
actually what's going on with like coin
19ks
i hope things will over soon but like uh
there's definitely
more work for all of us including us to
do
and in many cases monetary protection
levels and function are kind of like
relevant to like
how we fight uh with covet 19 like
diagnosing the problem you know like how
how heavy that diagnosis esp share tests
are really
wonderful to kind of like give you a
good uh
a good understanding of the of the
disease but like past infections or like
herd immunity when you're kind of
looking to other things
you kind of like involve immunoassays or
diagnose the problem understanding what
kind of proteins are
involved in this in this path then when
this virus is kind of like
working in the body uh what kind of like
receptors
it's using what kind of like antibodies
or like
what kind of like uh proteins it's it's
it's synthesizing and using
understanding all this mechanism how it
gets internalized to sell
what kind of like response body gives to
this disease
understanding all these requires you
tremendous amount of testing and these
are all immunoassays
and then developing therapies so there
are like uh i'm seeing two approaches in
code right now one is
like developing therapies as antivirals
actually to
to inhibit the reverse transcriptase
enzyme
in in in the cells uh and like how can
you like slow down specific to the viral
case
and like that will kind of like inhibit
the wider replication
and there are also like other therapies
for especially for patients who are
who's like in in cases actually their
body giving some
um some some some response inflammatory
response
that actually uh giving damage to the
body so in that case you're trying to
monitor different cytokine levels
and control them such that they should
to control the inflammation
so in that sense like it's it's it's
it's widely used we are seeing a lot of
papers actually publish around different
levels of cytokines how they play into
into into
into this disease and how kind of what
kind of treatments can be can be done
uh checking throughout the safety toxin
side effects there are a lot of drugs
being available
uh researchers are trying to put them
into trial clinical trials to see
actually if this drugs are
making the case better while not kind of
like harming the harming the patient you
know like checking the trap safety or
like monitoring the traffic efficacy
or later on like monitoring the immunity
past the faction for example
so like can you that is a big question
right now right can we have like
vastly available immunoassays that will
kind of like give us information about
like fast infection
immunity such that actually we can like
open up the
um uh workforce so in short uh this is
very relevant immunoassays are really
central to what's going on in this case
and we'll be
seeing actually more discussions going
around the actual immune essays their
shortcomings and advantages
uh in the next couple years i'm ugly so
i'm getting some technical details
so a license is one way of like
immunization that's the most common
available one that's i would say pretty
much a
segment and uh the basic principle is
like same in most immune essays
only the substrate and simple same
protocols change
so that's what we will be showing here
is applicable to other immunoassay parts
as well so
so the goal here is that you have a
biological sample coming from like human
sample
or mass study or it could be a cell
study and you have a target protein
x that you're trying to identify and the
concentration is
unknown and you're trying to get the
data so what you do is like you take an
elisa plate
you incubate your samples the target
protein gets captured
then after a couple of washes you put
the probing antibodies that signal is
correlated the concentration of that
unknown
through a standard curve so this is a
kind of highly
uh labor-some protocol so
it has like in 10 user steps using 10
micro 100 microsoft sample
typically takes four to eight hours we
do a lot of for example elizabeth
visualizes in our company to compare our
benchmark our
uh our uh our our microphone based
technology against and definitely like
typical time is like six to eight hours
it is uh
plus the data analysis and everything
like preparation
it's it's a complex i would say it takes
sometimes i want to have one and a half
days when you talk to customers that's
the what
they say to us so plus it's a 50 year
old technology so if you kind of like
look at
like how this technology developed and
evolved till today
uh it looks quite interesting so i want
to touch base with that as well so
so in this history the first even essay
recorded uh
was from the 1950s yellow van verson
first actually published a paper they
demonstrated actually imminence
excuse me uh incident level
let's say it was a level measurement
essay and and
that was such an impactful study that
actually and it opened up breakthrough
you're you have a sample and then you
have a molecule you're trying to measure
and you have you
you actually demonstrate a way to
measure that
entity that would that's a quite
breakthrough and uh and and and yellow
receives the
nobel prize in in 1977. uh
next uh next development comes around 71
uh where
engulf and program uh demonstrate the
enzyme amplification
and also solid phase uh essay so
basically this is kind of like
basically they demonstrate in the same
full stratum tube so this development 97
is what plate phase of license are today
so the technology since then has seen
really small changes
so another big breakthrough was in 75
kohler and
milstein uh they actually developed
hydrogen hybridoma technology which
enabled
to manufacture a specific molecular
antibodies
so before like the only way you can run
an essay was use some political
antibodies that you filter from the like
animal sources
that was like super low and inefficient
process so with this process actually
this process amplified a usage of
immunoassays and that led to a nobel
prize um
of course like this technology has also
other impacts in other fields of biology
as well
and then in 76 like should i demonstrate
that they can live in a sense
and since then like the technology is
still same so that's robust technology
still serves
thousands of biologists around the world
from big pharma to small farmers so
in 2000s we see adoption of normal
fascinating technologies
with the increasing need of multiplexing
i would say it was they say microarrays
enable end users to generate multiplex
data from a single sample
uh uh volume uh set
uh and digitally when i say the
microfluidic approaches also start to
emerge
so why this thing is so powerful and
has been there for 50 years with with
not much of a change first of all
uh it's a quite robust and powerful
method
it yields quantitative relevant and
actionable data
most often place the license in
particular doesn't require advanced
technology you have the plates you have
your
biomarkers you can homebrew your lysine
in-house the only thing you need is a
plate reader and just standard
so and and compared to many other essays
like
involving cells or other different kind
of like
uh essays where you have like more
complexity involved
they are quite robust so in that regard
uh
that's one reason they are the workforce
uh workforce to generate like
data over the last 56 70 years but
things are changing so
especially in the last five years we are
seeing actually new terror
approaches pushing the limits like
presentation medicine
or cell therapies or increasing need
with like point of care applications
or pharma's view of like data-driven
biology you know all these things
are pushing uh the limits of like
current enabling technologies
so in that sense better elisa
technologies that are more easily
generating data will be needed in for
emerging applications
like screening drugs for target specific
specific tumors
we have customers for example interested
in this application or quality control
for gene and cell therapy
or development of like biologics for
cancer applications
or ubiquitous diagnostics for infectious
disease and pandemics
like pandemic we are facing right now so
what we are starting to realizing
i can say that our last two three weeks
i read a lot of actually articles in
in in mass media about actually people
are questioning like why are like
testing infrastructure or technology and
also immunization essays included
are kind of like the state you know uh
and these are right questions to ask and
and also right questions to follow up uh
like definitely we are seeing that
protein data is lagging behind
because tools are slow labor intensive
and require too much sample so this is a
50 year old technology you have been
still
relying on so many application areas
reveal unmet needs in terms of
uh like for example when you're kind of
like talking to
a farmer customers from startups to big
pharma uh
what their this new applications demand
definitely more data points were given
volume and per given time
that is like repeating me coming around
uh sample volume reduction
so people are trying to get more data
from like small volume samples sometimes
because like samples are like
really really precious you have like
just a few microsoft sample you
want to generally maximize the data
output uh and
people are really kind of favoring
simple setup operate sas versatile
platforms that they fit to do like kind
of like mainstream flow of their lab
work
so they're not really interested like
okay this gives a solution but you need
to kind of like
to run that essay in that platform you
need to do a lot of different things
from different
directions to get let's say so that
really is not the ideal case
so most of the biologists are not
engineers at the end so increase dynamic
range this is also like coming
repeatedly especially related to
clinical trials and
preclinical when you dose a biological
entity and when you
say you need to guess what range your sa
will be
so and if your guess is wrong you need
to repeat that
diluting further or less increasing
sensitivity is a whole grail i think
this will be here for
50 years later as well so there is no
like
down limit so like lower is better
always
and speed for valdenic essays for new
targets so advisors are now being
treated that's like
elder slaw in terms of validating new
targets
so these are obviously everybody but
what are the bottlenecks why people
cannot come up with solutions
to enable or like transform this
technology to the next generation
so i would say like most of the
challenges in the field of minnesota's
can be categorized into
like two sections one is reagent reagent
related and one is the technology
related
so i want to cover first the rage at
related parts so in religion
reagent related part so antibody related
limitations first of all so
like if you want to run analysis
individualization you need to have
like two pairs of like antibodies
working well with that target
so antibiotic development process this
is a slow one
like even like you use hydroderma
technology it takes like weeks
definitely six weeks to a couple of
months uh and it's a highly experimental
process like after you do it you screen
and then you screen and you screen and
then finally you get like few of them
like working well enough
but this thing this risk is mitigated i
would say this was a big risk fifty
years ago right now there are like
zillions of like antibody companies uh
production qualities are
quite well uh antibodies are used as
therapeutics now so that also like
triggered more quality
uh control and increase uh so in that
sense especially if you're like
aiming for uh fundamental targets or
like widely
uh like utilized targets this is not
that big risk anymore i would say uh
protein stability concerns some proteins
are definitely hard to work it's
within outside of their native
environment like membrane proteins or
very vital capsid proteins in in viruses
for example
but these are specific cases need to be
treated as a specific
case and usually solutions exist that
utilizing different buffers or
detergents
so the major focus that i'll be focusing
next for nice few slides is the
biophysical limitations
so let's dive into biophysics of sample
incubation stabilizer
so on the right on the left what you see
this is
a protocol and we are focusing on to
that incubation
step which takes typically two hours to
an hour night where you put your sample
into an elisa plate where the valves are
decorated with capturing weights in this
case like
this green triangles are your capture
that say antigens
and their goal is to capture that
specific antibodies
in that sample so
first of all uh one thing is how good is
your
like antigen antibody like affinity you
know uh ideally you want
uh your antibody to have like f high
affinity to that against that antigen
such that like it binds well
and and load k off such that actually it
dissociates like
not much so this will ensure that
actually
the targets in the proximity of the
bottom will get captured well and when
once they get captured
they will not be released back to the
solution that fast so this can be
achieved by
selected antibody that has high affinity
against the target that's what
usually uh people do when they're
screening antibodies they try to find
the antibody
that actually has high affinity against
at the target
but then what kind of like gives you the
slowness in this case so
so the question is like how about
targets in the liquid that are away from
that close proximity let's say
this let's look at this antibody that's
kind of like millimeter away
just swimming inside the bulk fluid so
this this antibody this molecule needs
to kind of like do a random walk
diffuse over the hours uh it will do a
random walk
and get a successful interaction with
the bottom of the plate such that it
will get captured
so you're looking for an equilibrium
state that may take like hours
such actually you efficiently capture
some portion of the molecules in this
solution such that you can generate some
meaningful signal
so this is uh we call it like fishing
with the pole you literally
have the bait and then waiting in the
ocean for that molecule or fish to come
and find your bait
so although there are like new
technologies like base assays
microarrays
uh they're also impacted from this short
diffusion limited like transports uh
shortcoming
because at the end on a bead the
antibodies on the surface
and uh or or the or detection weight in
this case the antigen
is on the surface we are trying to
capture the other molecule
which is still in the ordinary
millimeter or like a couple of hundred
microns away
so in that sense there are still like
limited division limited
uh procedures that's why like if you
kind of read the protocols usually they
also suggest like bit based assays and
microarrays they also similarly
suggest like long incubation periods
so now we are getting into what kind of
solution we are
offering uh where microfiltrics meets
automation
to handle shortcomings
so i'll talk through a microfluidic
advancement uh
we went through so this project started
in collaboration with novartis and at
the time
we were in academia with my co-founders
and
and and and artists had this essay that
was used highly in
blood banks to confirm hepatitis c cases
so this was a strict assay that was that
was incubated in like long
quit that kind of like or a tube uh
which requires about one milliliter of
sample volume after some dilutions
uh and involves like 20 manual steps
and don't forget that like the test this
reagent that you're dealing with the
sample is
infectious uh and and then it's like six
hour long essay time so of course like
blood banks we're not
really super happy after like seeing
other technologies and automation
so uh so we had a project that like how
can we come up with a new method
that would actually simplify this essay
and increase the performance so
that was in the academic settings we
actually demonstrated i was lucky to be
part of this uh
this this team that where we actually
demonstrate that actually we can
take out those same regions that they
are using
uh through our collaboration they
generally provided and then demonstrated
as say
that we can run in the order of 20
minutes use two microliter samples
in a fully automatable format so that's
yield basically
10x faster sa requiring 500 x less
volume requirements so
so that was the start point so let's
dive into the
technology further uh so our technology
involves the microfluidic
chip where you have those channels that
are connected with
two valves where you put your samples
and things how things go
so what's happening inside that channel
is we have a hydrogel and
we have the technology to pattern the
hydrogen specifically so in this case
the greens that you see are like two
different proteins immobilized into the
gel body
and they are ready to kind of like serve
the assay so the sa
is is a standard elisa you have a bait
molecule to capture molecule you have
the target molecule in this case it's an
antibody and then a fluorescence
detection antibody
and if you have the reagent as you see
on the right for example c100p
antibodies are present in that patient
sample
that means to make sure that person's
like hepatitis c positive it gives the
signal
uh at that location so getting to like
the basics how our technology enables
like minutes long essays uh
let's dive into kind of like the core
technology in this case so getting back
to the
uh uh alright lately is the license
uh so once you kind of put your sample
in you're waiting for the diffusion
of this proteins that are especially far
away so that's why you were kind of like
we described this in a few slides before
that's why you incubate two hours to
overnight so what we do
we take the same reagents in this case
this green triangles and immobilize them
instead instead of a surface we
immobilize them into a gel hydrogel body
so
the hydrogel is simply a mesh of liquids
with nanopores and we immobilize these
antigens into this nanocores with our
technology and
and then put the sample into the valves
and airplane electric field and when the
sample
is sieving through uh the gel
if there are certain biomarkers that
have affinity to against that like
capture moieties in this case that
is getting three angles they get
captured so this capture process happens
in different orders of seconds
we are unlimited by the transport how
fast we can transport the reagents that
location
so we are basically introducing a
fishing with the nets
which provides an efficient electrically
driven
essay that is carried out in three
dimensions so it's more like a sidio
pseudo homogeneous essay i would say so
normally i had a video in the slide but
because of technical
difficulties i'm just like showing the
uh
initial and end point so what we see on
the left is
as we'll see a channel where there is
the detection zone and a net zone and we
are sending a target protein through
electrophoretic forces
and when that protein migrates into the
channel within 90 seconds of load time
uh it generates the signal you see on
the right and and the inert zone is of
course has no single signal the
the the reagent passed through that zone
generating this green curve on the
bottom the background signal over time
in the meantime the signal in the in the
detection zone accumulated
and then in 90 seconds we start the load
and then we
do a 20 seconds of electrophoretic wash
to remove on one material where you see
the background signal gets to the like
baseline level
whereas the like signifi this specific
signal
stays there steady so this 90 second
load
the that you missed to see uh in this
slide
is equivalent to two hours long sample
incubations definitely traditional lysa
and in this case it's completed in 90
seconds so that's how like our
technology increases the
uh capability to reduce the the
sa time uh our capture efficiencies are
really really high
uh so in in some applications where we
have
like a good antibody which has high
affinity
we see the signal really accumulating
the right end so what you see here in a
channel
in a uh which has actually multiplexing
features there are like four different
zones capturing different
uh different uh antibodies in this case
and if you look to like see
since we see 100p antigens on uh we see
the signal
is accumulated at the right edge of that
capture zone
so and and in d you're seeing the signal
profile
along the channel showing actually very
high signal at the right
edge so as soon as the antibodies enter
to that detection zone
they get captured before further
propagating into the detection zone
so our technology as i said in the
beginning we can do patterning in the
way that we want so we can do multiple
patterns in a single
single channel that gives us endless
multiplexing capabilities so in this
case you are seeing
two hepatitis c biomarkers immobilized
into a signal channel single channel
and and and then you kind of like send
the relevant
antibody first you only see a signal in
one uh
channel versus like if you see send the
other one in the others channel just
another channel and then finally if you
send like both
antibodies you see like both locations
light up
uh suggesting that actually you can like
detect two different entities
uh by two different uh capture moieties
that you can multiplex so what do you
all mean for the end user so
there is a microfluidics breakthrough
here and and there was a like interested
end user who was looking to replace
their technology so and what we have
here uh
you have a microfluidics expert team i
would say and and highly specialized
micro fedex lab involving a lot of
infrastructure and equipment
uh generating those fantastic results
what does it mean so as it is
unfortunate doesn't mean much and
unfortunately one
problem we are seeing in the field of
microfluidics is we see a lot of
locations but we are not seeing that
actually that this
nice publications transforming into
products and most of them actually
failed in this step
so complexity is the enemy so you need
to shield the end user from complexity
as most end users will respect that
there's innovation there there's a
hardware there there are a lot of like
weekends
uh evenings uh hard works miss parties
miss family events actually there's a
lot of like sweat there of course
but uh like at the end they kind of lift
their own like important stuff so at the
end you need to
have like automation and end user
simplicity
to shield the end user from your
complexity in that case you will
reach to a solution where it will
satisfy
the end user so any user cares about
getting data and getting data out of
this data very quickly
easily accurately and using as little as
a sample as possible
and your microfluidic breakthrough like
has the automation
which leads to the data
that's desired by the end user so then
you kind of like
happy end user and happy innovator so
our workflow uh
we are really like heading to simplify
the end user
experience so end user opens the
consumable cartridge that we provide
for that specific assay and they put the
the the cartridge into the robot and
they put the raw samples in the robot
and and from the same menu like they
select their specific sa
and run the essay that takes probably
three minutes ends on time
and then after a short break uh they
enjoy your
the their data our platform provides
scientists orders of magnetism or
the resolving power to quantify
biomarkers into small samples
by using 100 times less sample volume uh
and then providing data that's like 10
times faster so that yields combined
our platform can generate thousand times
more data
compared to existing platforms
for giving time and sample volume so
we introduced the technology and what
kind of new application areas
does this technology enable
so we broadly address the need for more
granular
data in terms of spatial and temporal
resolution for biomarkers
so rather than generating actual data
from a lot of samples
and like small number of samples we are
kind of like pushing to minimization
in terms of like both the sample volume
and increase the resolution granularity
there
uh especially and and generate data so
fast that actually you also get
temporary resolution
you have customers we are talking that
they usually do endpoint measurements
uh not because they want to or like
that's enough for them because actually
they cannot do really
in between uh essays and get actionable
data and then
probe their essays so that that doesn't
exist when we talk to customers they say
uh-huh like we can do
uh we can actually do rather than like
waiting an end point of the sa
i can just like probe my system a lot
earlier
and and and and actually like
make changes on the go or increase the
efficiency or yield of my
like other sa the real let's say they
are kind of like running behind so so
far like we are working
uh in this context uh five of the global
top 10
pharma companies and plus few other
cross and we have like multiple projects
uh
we are working on some of them were
completed successfully um
so i will just like walk through a few
uh case studies how our technology is
helping
uh these customers solve their unmet
needs an example application one
uh is the single animal's longitudinal
studies
in this case uh the the issue is like
preclinical pksas in mice or other
animals with precious
ratio samples and the problem is mice
have limited blood volume
and terminal assays which are leading to
death of the moss
to get the blood that's needed uh
increase variability of data and the
solution we offer
is one micro serum assays for
therapeutic proteins via teal vein bleed
where the the end user increases their
data quality reduce the cost
and happily the mouse continues to lie
live a little bit longer so in this case
study
when you kind of compare traditional
license versus correspond correlates
elisa
the traditionalizing records hundred
microsoft sample versus corellia
requires one microliters the variability
in elisa is really high because you're
getting
uh different data from different mice or
you're pulling things
versus corelia you're getting the same
data over the time period from the same
mouse basically
so in that sense you're using very less
mouse that
kind of like simplifies the sa and
increase the data quality and also
reduces the cost in terms of like
data this is the data we reported to the
customer in this project
uh we uh we generated standard
uh curve which
spends five log dynamic range with
industrial standard sensitivity
with excellent r square values of course
and
and using just one microliter raw sample
uh
to generate three data points in this
case and this was a repetitive human
molecule an antibody
tested in in the mouse theorem an
example application two
i'll be talking about tumor profiling in
a case from
uh precision medicine application uh
where uh where the end user profiling
primary tumor cells uh
from immuno-oncology clinical trial
patients so these are like
uh real cells coming from real patients
and grown in petri dish and probed
against different therapies to see how
they are like working
so and that says the problem is that
this patient's uh
primary tumor cells are difficult to
culture in peter dish and once you kind
of successfully culture them
like those by first of all biopsies you
have like small amount of material
plus after your culture that's that
material you're getting from spanish
nations are like highly precision
material so in this
project for example our collaborator our
customers sent us just 10 microliters of
sample per study
and asked us to generate data and we
used just like 2.5 microliters of that
volume to generate
tropical data points so like it is like
a two micro solution that we are
offering is like two micro through
cytokinesis
for screening uh primary
tumor sulfur spernatens against
therapeutic proteins
data looks pretty good we send them
comparison data compared to like
industry gold standards in this case for
example the commercial base uh
likes are having two laws of dynamic
range and 6.5
girls are meters limit of detection
requiring hundred microliters
and taking hours a day to complete
versus rsa giving five floor dynamic
range zero point six figures per meter
in order of magnitude lower sensitivity
and and
and 50 times less sample volume uh
requirement after dilution
so this in this graph we are comparing
our
curve standard curve to another
commercially
available vice platform in this case you
can see that like what
that's that wide dynamic range means to
the customer so if the customer is
starting an sa
using the competitor system where the
the concentration
of the target falls outside
that detection zone they will need to
repeat that sa so in our case
that's not the case five log is like
really generous
so the target will fall within that fine
dynamic range
and not only they will be saving another
experiment the experiment they are
running
will just use two microns of sample if
you'll have multiplex capacity
and run a lot a lot faster uh
overall this slide i wanted to just
discuss overall repeatability nsa
accuracy so on the left
you're seeing seeing like six standard
curves coming from
six patches of manufacturing uh where
the center curves are kind of like
a kind of like almost perfectly
overlaying each other uh
showing their excellent batch to that
repeatability
uh in terms of getting the more specific
cases uh
inter essay repeatability we are getting
around less than ten percent series
in this case this is like human i1 beta
target and for
intra essays repeatability within the
same essay
we are seeing down to five percent uh
essays and
and good news is like with every project
every uh
experiment we are doing we are seeing an
increase in our series so
in the next six months we are hoping to
report cvs below five percent
so in short innovative core technology
merged with automation
pushed limits across multiple dimensions
by orders of magnitude
and gives freedom to customers to
operate
the sa have controlled their sa in the
way they they want so they have kind of
like
they have a sample volume limitation you
get a check mark
they need the fastest aid they get the
charge mark uh they need a
long right large detection range of
dynamic range
they get what they want they need a
multi-text sa to
test multiple biomarkers at the same
time and check mark so in that sense
we are getting a lot of interest and we
are hoping that actually this technology
will be serving a lot more
uh people generating relevant data and
move faster
with the results and get their therapies
to those patients
the more timely manner and also reduce
the cost
that's our motivation so ongoing and
future application areas include
human blood certain biomarkers multiplex
diagnostics and rapid point of care
tests
so uh uh due to the time limit i didn't
discuss here but couple of years ago we
completed a project with nih
and uh and in that project we delivered
actually a nine volt battery operated
handheld instrument
which fully runs the essence that we are
talking about here
in a point-of-care fashion in a
miniaturized fashion in a fully
automated way
in less than 15-15 minutes so
if you are interested if you have
interest in these areas feel free to
get in touch to get more information or
see
how we can help solving or
addressing your your essay needs or
unmet needs
so this is a definitely changing field
uh i will say next five years the next
10 years will be more interesting than
today
uh so in this regard we are definitely
interested for hearing from you
uh your questions comments suggestions
reach us at
info cordeliabayer.com and if you want
to specifically reach me you just use
lab roots cursed in the keyword
and that will make sure that actually
i'll be seeing that email
as well so with that i would like to
thank you very much
looking forward to hearing from you
thank you